in this video we'll be talking about the
ATP depletion and its relation with cell
injury that's a high ill topic so watch
this video till the end so cell injury
is due to the stress that a cell suffers
due to an external or might be internal
environmental changes so there are many
organal such as mitochondria endoplasmic
reticulum nucleus and membrane are
highly susceptible to this kind of
cellular injury so there are different
outcomes of cellular injury cell would
obviously try to adapt to the stress and
overcome it but in extreme cases when it
is irreversible and irrepairable cell
have to die and there are
stresses which lead to Cellular
adaptation and a different video I have
talked about it and cell injury could be
reversible as well it's not always
irreversible but there are some times
injurious injurious stimulus which are
so strong that
revers reversible injury reversible uh
process is not possible in that case
death is inevitable so necrosis or
apoptosis happens one such stress that
cells undergo is basically the ATP
depletion so let's see why ATP depletion
is important but before that let me tell
you cell can get injury in many ways
there could be physical damage like
trauma radiation heat that can
physically damage the cell there could
be internal damage for example hypoxia
which might be a cause might might be
due to anemia isia cardiopulmonary
failure or some kind of poisoning all
these thing can lead to Cellular injury
and ATP depletion and let me tell you
how so ATP depletion is really crucial
for cell because ATP is the cellular
energy currency you need to do anything
the cell basically needs ATP just like
you need cash or money every day to kind
of like fulfill your needs your
day-to-day chores your food groceries
everything cell and the enzymes inside
the cell need ATP for these kind of
purposes let us try to appreciate that
for example any cell which is
metabolically active had to like uh had
to depend on several biochemical
Pathways let's say glycolysis let's say
kreb cycle etc etc so basically all of
that Pathways require some amount of ATP
any anabolic pathway for example making
new proteins making DNA all these kind
of anabolic prats require ATP secondly
any cells which are dividing for example
stem cells for example many other skin
cells all dividing cells require a huge
amount of ATP to
divide processes like DNA replication
which is a prerequisite for division
Gene activation transcription
translation all these things require ATP
in specific steps without ATP any of
these central dogma processes cannot
happen also the cells need to
communicate with each other the cell
need to recept signal from outside so
those cellular signaling also requires
ATP in various steps many enzymes just
to give you an example kyes enzymes
which are crucial for several
biochemical pathway requires ATP for
phosphor hilting substrates that is why
ATP is so crucial but where does cell
get ATP from so one of the major source
of ATP is basically glycolysis and the
transport chain you remember this
biochemical 101 Series so basically
under fade condition when glucose is
abundant nutrient is abundant cell would
try to make ATP using glucose but in
also in fasted State cell would break
down the existing molecule such as fat
to generate ATP so basically ATP is
required whether you are in a fusted
state or a Fed state so basically how
does ATP depletion can occur
so there could be various reason like
lack of oxygen lack of nutrients
mitochondrial damage chemical toxicities
like cyanide poisoning poisoning so
imagine that Etc or electron transport
chain remember cyanide binds to the A3
portion of the complex 4 and thereby
preventing this
particular uh electron transport chain
also oxygen serves as the final electron
acceptor in the electron transport chain
to form H2O so once oxy is depleted or
there is a lack of oxygen this
particular step cannot happen so
entirely this would affect the oxidative
phosphorilation process and the result
is low ATP imagine there is an hypoxia
and due to the lack of oxygen there are
problems in the cell for example the
sodium potassium ion exchange pump which
operates based on ATP hydrolysis would
not work in a proper
way and why this is not happening
because enough ATP is not generated so
Etc is
compromised also enzymes like kyes
enzymes would not function optimally now
many of these kyes enzymes are actually
involved in many cell signaling Pathways
such as the map kyes signaling pathway
it's a kyes Cascade each time ATP is
required and ATP has to be hydrolized to
phosphorate substrates so these kind of
signaling would be abrogated now mapk
signaling and many other signaling which
requires phosphorilation are crucial for
cellular growth so if these signaling
pathways are abrogated the physiological
consequences is also not good also low
ATP can cause stress like ear stress it
can lead to a disregulation of the
metabolism anerobic glycolysis would be
increased enough amount of lactive acid
would be produced so the cellular pH
would be dropping down which might lead
to which further aggravate the ear
stress the ribosomes present on the ER
would detach the protein synthesis would
break down or prot protein synthesis
would be reduced so there are many many
adverse cause of ATP
depletion any cellular process you might
think of would be abrogated when the ATP
levels are low for example any of these
U central dogma processes replication
transcription translation it would never
happen if there is not enough ATP self
wouldn't even think of dividing if there
is a low ATP levels so cells like stem
cells which has to divide all the time
in order to produce and regenerate new
cells they would never divide because
ATP is low cells which are highly
metabolically active like the
hepatocytes they would face a lot of
challenges because they have to run a
lot of biochemical pathway in normal
time to function properly so their
function would be compromised from a
cellular from a molecular and from a
physiological level there would be a
huge compromisation of normal function
that is why ATP is so important and ATP
depletion is such a detrimental uh
cellular stress so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can say share
our uh Channel link with your friends
you can follow us on social media see
you in next video all the links are
provided in
description